so I'm an infectious disease data
scientist which means that in practice I
should be spending all my time sort of
chasing pathogens and understanding why
we get them all what the vulnerabilities
are and so forth but in reality it means
that I spent a lot of time juggling data
and fussing with computers and so forth
I was on the bioinformatics team that
handled the 2009 swine flu outbreak the
global pandemic okay we were also the
people who got the first sequences of
mares called the Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome coronavirus that
are still blitzing through Saudi Arabia
and I was also involved in the
accidental outbreak of foot-and-mouth
disease a couple years before that and
my friends described my Twitter feed as
a constant torrent of sorrow and misery
okay so here are some contact details in
there I used to work for Health
Protection Agency UK but I'm currently
based at Imperial College at the
historic Paddington campus tour buses go
by underneath my window which you can
see in the upper right there just to
slither of it and they announced the
site as saying here is where prince
george was born nothing about the
discovery of penicillin that took place
in the windows on the left of that
picture but there you have it okay now I
feel like a bit of a fraud today because
there's not going to be a single bit of
maths or a symbol or anything like that
and I don't actually even think I have
an explicit line of code or graph or
anything like that what this is is a war
story from a research project in
progress what we did in a data intensive
biomedical project why we did almost
everything wrong and how we managed to
survive that nonetheless so there's lots
of high level details tools and
techniques here's what we did here's the
things you use here's the possible
pitfalls not everything I talk about is
Python but python is the glue that holds
it all together and that made it
possible so that's a good enough excuse
there
now there are some specific names and
details that I will not be mentioning
because I just don't want to get bogged
down into the mire of why someone's
favorite databases in fact a terrible
piece of rubbish okay but we'll get to
them as we go along so a background is
this huge infectious disease research
project okay the high-level concept is
if a child is bought into an emergency
room with an apparent fever what have
they got why have they got that why are
they suffering from that much worse than
another child that is not so we're
looking at the sort of determinants of
disease vulnerability in there and as a
consequence we have this vast body of
data that we've built up we are
collecting information from over 20
sites from over a dozen countries
scattered across Europe and one in
Africa we currently have more than 5,000
patients and aiming to hit more than
10,000 by the end of the year and they
have had the full diagnostic detailed
gauntlet thrown at them we've got the
clinical signs that doctors collected
the emergency room they've taken their
heartbeat they've taken their blood
they've cultured their blood okay we've
got the timelines of everything that's
happened to them okay we've got all the
operations they've had all the
treatments they've been given to them
we've of course this being a genetic
project we've gone holy into the
sequencing okay we've done gene
expression all of that stuff so
naturally this is a very huge complex
data set and it was of course put into a
very robust very well-designed and
intricate database no okay and
thankfully this all took place before I
came on board okay a few words about the
world of clinical research databases now
there is
this huge market out there for these
large epidemiological trials okay to
manage all these sort of patient records
pharmaceutical companies use them okay
medicos use them to run these tests and
so forth and they are very expensive
high-end pieces of equipment I won't
mention the particular one we were using
but it rhymes with more achill now of
course the design and data analysis
details and so forth should have been
given huge consideration at the start of
this project but as is often the case
there was this idea we'll just buy the
top of the market and everything will be
fine and that did not take place we
invested I say we're in the Royal since
of course it was not me we invested in
this very expensive clinical research
database we invested in a third-party
team to host and take care of that
database design it for us although no
one actually took care as to whether
they had any experience in doing this
with an epidemiological trial of this
size in fact no one actually had
experience in this database I did from a
previous job and it is well reputed to
be a right only database you can record
all your information and it will be nice
and safe in there and will never be
coming out okay of course we want to
know things about this data okay we want
to report on and analyze it and so forth
and there are these very intricate
complicated reporting tools in there
that sometimes give you the wrong answer
for example one time we wanted to see
what sort of blood pressures our
patients had and it's giving us an
average figure of 300 millimeters of
mercury which you know could adequately
be described by there's blood gushing
out of these people and hitting the roof
for the emergency room the system
crashes occasionally okay wonderful we
can't get a direct sqlconnection that's
just not possible okay we can't get
stats package connection to it dito it's
just beyond the skill level of most of
our users to actually do anything with
this thing and so we have this huge body
of information in there that we can't
actually use so what do we do the whole
of the project is kind of contingent
upon all the information that is trapped
in this system but we do have one winter
one crevice of a way of getting at that
data and we are able to convince them to
send them as a regular dump of the
database now it's not an SQL dump it is
a set of nearly 200 raw text files just
pour it out from the system and so we
immediately started to study them the
schemer of the database is interesting
to say the least it's changed several
times during production because no one
quite adequately thought about the sort
of things that we might want to ask and
so forth and so several times during the
trial peoples had asked for features to
be added and so the schema was modified
and indeed sometimes just entire tables
were duplicated and changed slightly so
we actually had patient data lost
isolated within this system yeah the
namings and nature of things was a
unique combination between
computer-generated arbitary alpha
numeric digits and operators that could
not spell those one particular
delightful part in the database where we
recorded whether we took a sample of
someone's blood and it was how many of
those samples we took and what the
volume of those samples were and
everywhere in the database they were
systematically put in the other column
the number was in the volume the volume
was in the number okay so we've got 200
files here of stuff and I have a team of
clinicians breathe
think down my neck saying get us this
information it's important I don't
understand what's so difficult about it
hmm now of course when you're faced with
this we had several false attempts at
trying to get things out of there your
initial inclination of course is to just
start writing code and will extract
something line by line by line but the
mats of this is fairly if you'll sit
down and think about if you spend ten
minutes working out which each field is
and you've got more than 2,000 these
fields you're going to be here for the
next two and a half months having worked
through weekends having work long nights
and everything just doing this
extraction and we do not have this time
okay so we have to mobilize this data
into something we can actually use and
fortunately there is this lovely tool
called CSV to SQL okay and it does
exactly what it says on the tin it can
turn a comma separated value file into
SQL and you can inject that into a
database and boom you've got a database
there it's part of this it's a small
part of this lovely kept called CSV kit
of course that has that unique swiss
army knife variety i only do one thing
and I do it well and that's work with
CSV files I search them i split them
I'll turn them into all sorts of things
and so we were able to get these CSV
files and I can turn that into an SQLite
database now you can have it
automatically infer a schemer and it's
pretty good at doing that however the
date formats within the database were
eccentric and differed from column to
column and you I could have provided it
with an explicit schemer but instead I
just said let's keep it as it is and
just convert it all as text so we have
here a recreation of what our original
device is right good old SQL we can
actually query this thing
get stuff out of there and there we have
our 200 tables so rather than write code
loaned by line how can we somehow
sanitize this clean this up and get it
mobilized in as fast as possible this
massive task rather than express it all
just as code when I did was embed the
entire process as a series of tables
rules okay what column and table are we
extracting the data from where is that
going to and then set up a chain of
sanitization rules that goes after that
now the value in this is that rather
than we create a large monolithic
program that defies any adaptation and
explanation for later modification and
we are going to have to modify this when
we understand what we've done wrong we
have all our transformations captured in
one place that table itself can form the
basis for documentation we need merely
write a script to process over that and
it can tell us where everything is going
from we're having is going to and we can
give it to someone and say check this
out this is what's happening what's
wrong with that we also explicit this
allows us to explicitly do it as an
evolutionary approach because the
clinicians are wanting their data now
okay and once again we're not going to
get it right so we have to accept the
fact that errors will be found and we've
actually recruited the users therefore
in sporting the errors that go back to
us we can correct that table and shoot
it through so we get our original data
in our set of rules we run it through
our sanitizers and we have this huge
list of sanitizers we've borrowed from
various places and if this sort of
philosophy I've taken from ian's bicking
okay have a chain of sanitizers to do
things to think fix the date on this
throw it to the next sanitized
fix something of their throat the next
one if we have an error condition or
something like that error out I can
catch it I can see what case is not
being handled and I can go back to it
now because we have a large amount of
data recorded in different places for
the same result the same let's go over
there again let's see we have the same
piece of information recorded in
multiple places in the database because
of the changing in the schemer through
time we have to in a lot of cases right
to the same location so in all of these
cases what we do is we run over location
the database if there is if it does not
produce anything substantial we don't
record that information because
something else might write over it later
on we then can write this to my records
we can run a post validation process
over it to check that we have actually
done a validation correctly so for
example check logical things like the
patient was admitted to the hospital
before they actually left the hospital
the patient's blood pressure is actually
within reasonable parameters and so
forth and we can do certain
post-processing to make our information
more useful front end users okay and
then we upload this or rather we create
a neutral format we can transform this
into a database for our users they can
criticize to say what the hell is this
this makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever and we can go back and we
just can keep iterating over this so
recruited a lot of eyes to actually spot
the problems in the data now creating a
database yeah this of course is
something we're doing all the time but
as someone in at the informatics
bioinformatics I will be perfectly happy
never to create another database ever
again and that is because
they are very often created lightly for
a perceived need in science and then
never used back at the Health Protection
Agency we at one point did a census of
all the databases that we had all the
ones that everyone had said it'll be
really great if we had a database on and
we had nearly a hundred databases we had
created over the years for all sorts of
things here they're in everywhere the
number of ones that are actually used
was something like 20 and each one of
those everyone said it'd be a great idea
if we had this so how can we shortcut
this how can we fulfill my ambition to
never create another database ever again
and it has to be user friendly to
satisfy our clinicians okay it has to be
secure because we are talking about
personal identifiable information here
there are very strict penalties if we
manage to leak any medical information
out there and it has to have all the
reporting tools and everything that
weren't present in this high-end
clinical database out there and the
answer is this thing called red cap okay
now this is not a Python tool but you
can work with it with Python and it is
absolutely wonderful okay okay red cap
is basically a your standard let's throw
a database up on the web application and
it has this very easy very nice to
create you lightweight process to create
databases within it it allows you to run
reports export and variety of formats
start our CSV Excel lalala so on and so
forth it's got a REST API so you can
actually interact with thing you can do
file sharing stuff like that now it does
have slightly weird licensing conditions
in that it is free but not freely
available it's issued out of Vanderbilt
University and when you contact them
they go through this ornate procedure
about wanting you to
make an agreement between your
organization and their organization and
you become a local redcap contact and
it's all just a little bit like a cult
okay but in terms of being able to just
freely throw a database like a table up
on the web it is awesome and in fact in
a number of labs they've started to make
quite heavy use of this Scott Burns who
wrote a couple of packages to work with
red cap used to come from a lab where
every data set they generated would just
get pushed up into red cap installation
okay tap into the rest interface push it
up the data set is there everyone may
work with it so that fulfills my
ambition there now it also has another
aspect that's very useful in terms of
this current situation which is how you
managed to create the databases as well
okay it has your standard GUI visual
editor where you can select a field and
so on so forth but it also has a thing
called a data dictionary which is just
simply downloads a spreadsheet okay with
that design information in there you
edit that spreadsheet information re
uploaded it changes the database schema
for you and it is fairly good about
changing the schemer migrating the data
and the appropriate way there so you can
iteratively evolve your database in an
interesting way okay make things the way
you need them to be very fast now there
is a Python package spiked up by the
aforementioned Scott Burns okay that
talks to the rest api for red cap and
this means that we can upload data
download data we can modify the schemer
of the rest all of the things so now we
have boom a pipeline we can pour our
data out of that old and crappy database
that all these clinicians and research
nurses are still busily entering
information into and we can transform it
through our sanitation pipeline we can
upload it into red cap and their people
can criticize it okay and we can repeat
the procedure over and over again and we
can get that going from start to finish
in an hour so that's wonderful this
saves me huge amount of work and I can
actually get do interesting things with
that data yeah but here is where the
catch comes in okay and it's
particularly when it's a life sciences
issue I think but it's particularly
poignant in these medical trials and
epidemiological trials epidemiological
data is some of the worst data in the
world and I know everyone has bragging
rights over this and says no my data is
the worst I defy you hmm okay mine is
much worse epi data is collected by
humans of course and so therefore there
will always be distortions a doctor is
having to make a judgment on a set of
symptoms in a clinic is this child sick
are they severely sick not that that
goes a thing you have lots of shall we
call them social factors involved as
well in Greece they hand out antibiotics
like can you so you've got a bunch of
children dying from weird antibiotic
resistant infections you're Albanian
contact would really like to be helpful
but he hasn't got any data so every
couple of months he sends a couple of
marginal cases because otherwise you
might forget about him and the British
hospitals tend to act as feeders or
sources for the outline regional
hospitals so you get a strange number of
severe cases appearing at your major
hospitals they're making it look as if
you have an epidemic for what you have
done is actually just selected them out
of the greater pool of the UK so there
are many possible confounding factors
and if we're looking at the doing
genetic correlates as well we don't only
just need the severe cases we also need
mild cases too if we want to understand
what the differences are between someone
who gets very sick from disease and
someone who gets mildly sick we need
that whole span but we have this strange
distorted data
it with a whole ton of missing data in
there because we designed this cockeyed
overly complex questionnaire that
harried doctors and nurses sittin in
emergency rooms just don't have the time
to fill in so there are huge gaps all
over it so we need to explore our data
as before we had many false attempts on
going through with that you know it
seemed natural for a start to do a bit
of machine learning over it surely if we
get some sort of ml technique or we get
scikit-learn so forth and we throw it at
this data it will be able to tell us
what we're distortions are there it will
be able to give us some explanation or
where or loss of your cases are coming
from unfortunately our data set just is
too weird okay the primary problem is
the missing data okay there is missing
data from almost every record that we
have within the database there and it is
difficult if not impossible to know how
to impute or infer that missing data
sometimes a missing data means no
sometimes the missing data just means
missing so we did some very crude very
rough and ready things on it and if
anyone has any better suggestions I
would be more than happy to hear so we
construct a severity score from our
patients an artificial number running
from zero to five okay just based on
their outcome if they died well that's
very severe okay if they ended up in
intensive care well it's the next grade
down and so on and so forth so we have
this slightly arbitary score there we
won hutton code all our categoricals and
lord do we have a lot of categoricals
and that data set the country's the
particular types of ventilation used so
on and so forth and then using banned us
we just do one big major correlation
matrix and look for what the weird
things in their arm this actually turned
out to be very reassuring because it it
told us that the doctors when I call
something a severe case we're actually
usually right and the sort of symptoms
they are interpreted but it also picked
out a number of other things weird
subcategories of patients and in there
that you know it's a correlation with
the center that collected those patients
because they tended to see a particular
type of people there's another
correlation with the particular disease
because some investigator has an
obsession with that disease whenever he
hears the one he flocks in and he adds
it to the trial and so forth so we were
able to winnow out some of our weird
cases from there our second approach was
to use this other tool called orange
okay now orange is yet another data
visualization and analysis tool out
there but it's good nonetheless it
allows you to set up pipelines for
manipulating data and visualizing data
and you can do this in a visual editor
once again or you can do it with Python
either way it's all handy the best thing
that orange has for this particular
purpose is you can give it a categorical
output variable say severity say country
or whatever like that and then say run
through the data set and find me the
best projections or I think they call it
the most interesting projections and it
will come back often with dozens of
graphs and say this one looks quite
interesting and you can see how it's
separated out all your patients in ways
that they shouldn't have been all our
Austrian patients are shifted out and
sitting separate for our English
patients and our German of patients and
so forth so we're able to identify
another couple of cohorts of weird
things in there now okay we finally we
finally after the enter this terrible
data after the end of kind of pick out
cases that are actually cases that are
worth investigating and so forth we now
actually want to get something out of
this information and disease genomics I
would propose is one of the most
interesting data analysis problems there
are because it's a classic friend of a
friend problem and disease is a
multi-level phenomena many things can go
go in to go into causing you have a
disease do you catch it easier are you
resistant to it is there something
within your system that means that you
have a more severe case is it your
location that you're in so forth and we
can get the same phenotype the same
outcome from a whole series of different
changes within a person so a complex
macromolecule summer in the body is
malfunctioning okay and this causes you
to suffers and severely from infection
it could be from something that is
regulating or modifying that particular
molecule or it could be from the piece
of nucleic acid that's transcribed off
that goes to create that macro molecule
or it could be the gene that codes for
that nucleic acid or it could be all
these other genes interact with and
control these things so we are very
often talking about causes are several
steps removed and we need to examine
these things within that context we
can't just say what let's have a look at
all these patients and look for the
common cause because while they have may
have common symptoms they may have
different underlying causes due to the
complex pathways underlying them run
these analyses we also get a huge amount
of noise as well too and this is
something that comes through all these
life science problems that almost in a
sense getting results is not difficult
it's picking out the interesting results
it's picking out the useful things so
because this is data science and no one
does anything is boring as a database
anymore let's go and use a graph
database
hmm but this actually makes a great
sense I am a rank beginner and graph
databases and there are other people at
this meeting who are much better experts
at it but to give you the high level it
would be much like our no SQL or object
databases we're restoring things in the
database except that relationships
between objects are a first level
citizen okay graph databases are very
interested in the connections between
things and how we can traverse them so
we can ask all these questions like
these two objects here the things they
connect to what do they have in common
and many more complicated questions now
the one which dozens neo4j it is the
most popular one out there and there are
various Python tools work with them now
this allegation has been made than in
the future maybe all databases will be
graph databases I think that's fairly
dubious in theory there is probably
nothing here that you couldn't do with a
conventional database but it's the level
of expression that's much more useful
and interesting for us so let's get all
this results all these information there
transform them let's connect it to a
whole bunch of old genomic and clinical
information as all these databases out
there and let's see what we come up with
schema design for this sort of stuff is
hard because your choices about
relationships invariably impact the sort
of queries that you can do later and we
had lots of false starts about how this
data would be transformed fortunately in
terms of getting the existing corpus of
genomic databases and pathway databases
and all this other information out there
into this pool someone's already done
the hard lifting these guys called
bio-forge a the installation is enormous
it's over a terabyte of data
but when you merge it all in and you mix
it all up you get something like this
now you know you're at a data science
conference because I've put up the
spaghetti picture at last yeah and we
can actually start to interrogate this
data and ask it questions like these two
patients have the same outcome what
defects or variants are we seen in their
genes and how can those be linked
together in the variant pathways that
are out there and we can actually start
to understand the research project that
we set on all the way back when yeah so
a couple of take-home lessons and things
like that and they will probably not be
very surprising and it's not that data
analysis and data design really has to
be done at the beginning of the project
rather than during or in flight when or
whatever and this point is so very
obvious but in academia and research
projects and so forth it is so often
thought of an afterthought data science
and analysis in a sense has been we've
allowed it to be turned into mere
programming so you have pile of data
dumped on you and said make sense of
this whereas all of these issues all of
these months spent on trying to
transform this data trying to make sense
of it throwing out all these cases that
we've carefully collected and so forth
could have been avoided if we'd started
to think about these issues right back
in the beginning and this is so obvious
but it's going to happen again and again
of course this whole academic research
project thing is very different from a
lot of the things that people are
working in here but these genomic
projects these days they are all about
information and data analysis and yet at
the same time academia and research can
be very hostile to these data science
projects Terry artwyrd had a
an interesting paper recently on
biological research databases examining
the half-life of them you set up a
database on some vital target how long
is it likely to hang around sometimes
the database is shut down before the
paper has been published on it okay data
science is not something that gets taken
very seriously in academia but it is
something that it needs life science
data problems the sort of ones I've
talking about are in a sense very
different from the things that other
people look at hear people talk about
I've got a million customer rose we need
to get eyeballs and our website aight i
say i've got five thousand records and
they're all terrible yeah very often the
issue is being able to make sense of
large but not vast but very detailed
records and get them out of there
evolution beats revolution and tools and
on a lifestyle and these are two things
I feel kind of very passionate about all
too often I've wasted huge amounts of
time on tools and revolutionary
techniques and things like that that
just said if I would invest much more
time and undo these particular
approaches then your life will become
wonderful but being able to do this
either approach to solve this data
problem being able to get something out
to people and having them criticize it
wildly and then go back again and again
and set this chain up worked in this
particular case using something as dumb
as SQL and so forth worked very well so
we've got expertise in that it just
works redcat just works so forth tools
that just work are great for me because
it means that I can just do these things
and then get on to the actual
interesting part of the work i'm sure
you can google for all the things that i
uploaded i'll mention along the way here
are some else in there and that's it
thank you very much
hi um I've been over and red cup very
much but when you were describing it um
I was wondering um how much help was
giving you from maybe someone who knows
SQL a lot and given CSV files you can
just load directly that into tables
right okay it's hmm okay there's lots of
points there are of course one of the
issues of academic informatics is that
you're very often stuff on your own as
like you to solve this problem and so
forth so I did not have an SQL expert
there I mean a lot of the meta data and
information and need almost all of it
had just been stripped from those tables
by the time it got to meet they were
really very context free and the
internal schema was one of the most
bizarre things I'd ever seen possibly
someone who is an SQL expert might have
been able to make at a sense of it I
fancy not because so much of it had been
automatically generated it was a very
strange hyper denormalized structure
inside there where you would have the
same bit of information occurring 10 12
times in different tables maybe someone
might have been able to make better
sense but yes that person was not
available to me I maybe I have a second
question how many solid or later name is
probably a similar answer cuz I'm coming
more from the subway engineering
background and and to say my last job
I've started working with a that with
fascinate me and didn't know even very
much and having just CSV files and
probably loading directly into a skilled
but also I was asking myself well is it
easier if those CSV information which we
don't know anything about the schema put
in earnest kimmel s database layer
say pain was nice queuing I mean I'm not
saying crap eight the basis because
that's not much more complicated right
but something like more wood to be which
is just documents off mmm okay um right
now we did consider a scheme Alice
database along the way um I'd done a
little bit of playing around with such
things in consideration of them and I
certainly won't say that my opinion is a
hugely informed one my impression was
that scheme Alice databases do have a
schemer it's just implicit right okay
and you know and they're so therefore
you know a scheme Alice database in a
sense is a useless database if I don't
know what the things are there in there
so it may have been a better solution in
the long run I don't know but it's it
was probably not a time to invest in
risky technologies when we had this
whole trial hovering on this particular
outcome right okay thank you